did you notice anything
from from when you went through in 1969
and and then you fast forward what 20
something years
was there anything that you said oh they
got soft over here they got weak over
here this is easier or this is harder
i'm gonna say it got harder
and uh
so i take over as the ceo of the uh of
the center and uh
one of the things that i did was i i
looked at the
schedules for
the uh
each of the different phases uh
and i i also looked at you know all the
schedules for the advanced training
because one of the things i wanted to do
is i wanted to go out
and and observe uh you know observe the
class observe the instructors
i went and i spent time out of san
clemente island when i was the uh the
commanding officer uh yeah i went to uh
to wherever there was uh wherever there
was training
uh
so
take over as a skipper and i'm looking
at the the training schedules now
when i went through training
i do not recall
a training day
that started
we had to be on the line at zero 700.
and that was after breakfast so we
didn't you know form up uh but uh
training started at zero 700.
and uh
i uh
got to training
and i'm looking at the uh i'm looking at
the schedule
the zero four hundred zero four hundred
zero four hundred zero four when i went
through it was early
and this particular thing that uh jumped
out at me was a zero five thirty or zero
five
or zero five fifteen
four mile time run
and i'm saying
what the hell is this [__]
[Laughter]
you know
i was saying that too i was doing them
so uh whether it was the first phase of
the second phase you know they came up
to me and
i said you know
what are we doing here well that's the
uh
that's the uh the only uh only low tide
and
that guy
is one of the luckiest guys in naval
special warfare because my question was
how [__] stupid do i look
[Laughter]
one high tide in the morning one low
tide in the morning one eye in the
afternoon one low in the afternoon
and uh that that is not cast in stone
because there are a certain number of
days in the year uh where you only have
uh you know
combination of three tides you know you
know you'll get two highs
i said
do not
even think about
opening your mouth to say anything else
about the tides
but to my point
they were they they were now doing uh
four mile time runs and maybe an o
course or uh another session before
breakfast
and uh like i say we we didn't do that
now when we uh when we were out at san
clemente island
there was no schedule it was you know 24
hours a day yeah uh but uh uh other
otherwise uh you know of course there
were uh there were night swims uh you
know anyways of course when you get uh
it wasn't like uh you know seven to five
every day yeah you you might have uh
uh
you know night uh you know night
navigation or we'd uh we'd go up to
different places for uh orienteering and
so on and again uh you you you throw the
clock out the window just because of uh
because of what you're doing but uh
basically
uh
when we were at the strand it was a uh
it was a seven to five or seven to five
thirty or again you talk about night
dives and so on of course you're working
till uh you know 10 11 midnight whatever
it might be
uh so
so it it has changed they are they are
putting uh at least uh 12 or 15 pounds
into a 10 pound bag
uh i mean they are really uh
they're using every every every minute
of the day
so if somebody asked me is training
harder today you bet your ass it is
and the gut the kids are in better shape
they're all they're all in better shape
so like if you're running with your boat
crew
you're you're running with guys that are
able to run faster so you better better
be able to run faster they're just all
in better shape i was over there a
couple of years ago and one of my
buddies was now a civilian working there
and we were having the same conversation
and we were standing out by the first
phase office
and he you know there's a hundred
helmets lined up
and
and he said you know he goes look at
these hundred whatever it was 122
helmets he was every one of these guys
i'm telling you was a stud
and they're gone
he's like this program is hard i said
yeah roger that it's a heartbreaking
program